being close to the terminally ill needs
a new layer of care during the
coronavirus crisis we filmed Pat cowling
from outside her hospice window keeping
a safe distance for the nurses and
assistants here they must wear gloves
aprons and masks but a national shortage
means it's a scramble each week to
source the gear supplies are due to run
out within days unless more is delivered
we're having to contact people to beg
steal and borrow from different
different agencies and different
organizations who were all always
willing to help us but it always seems
that it's only when you get to that
critical crisis point that suddenly some
PPE will arrive it's a plea heard across
the health sector from frontline
hospitals to hospices under pressure
ministers said a shipment of supplies
would arrive today it is the case that
there's a consignment of personal
protection equipment that's arriving
from Turkey which contains tens of
thousands of gowns but barely two hours
later it emerged the just-in-time
delivery had been delayed not good
enough say medics this is devastating
news I'm so sorry for our doctors and
their patients and I would like to ask
the government the words of the minister
himself Robert Jen Rick what should we
do shipments have been coming in from
overseas including this plane load from
China but there's global competition and
limited supply now the government has
charged the man who oversaw the London
Olympics with boosting the production of
protective equipment at home we do
recognise that we need to be working
constantly in order to be able to boost
supplies this is why we brought in law
Dayton we don't want to see anyone in a
setting that doesn't have the equipment
that they need to do their job but
that's exactly the risk the nurses at
this hospice face if their stocks run
out their patients really don't have
time for any delay Deborah Haynes Sky
News